it's been a steady flow of people
walking down this road carrying whatever
they could grab before they left their
homes everyone was spoken to says
there's been heavy fighting between the
Congolese Army and the M23 Rebel Group
which is widely understood to be a proxy
of neighboring Rwanda although Rwanda
denies it military sources say the two
sides have been fighting heavily with
artillery which is very dangerous for
the civilians people we've spoken to
here say almost the entire civilian
population of the town of kibumba has
fled
we were asked by soldiers to leave all
of us the soldiers were pursuing the
rebels and told us to go the other way
we heard a lot of bombs and there are
many people coming down this road
there was a lot of gunfire we walked
through the night and then slept on the
roadside we have carried almost nothing
with us we left everything behind and we
were very hungry
military sources told us m23's attack
began with a barrage of dozens of
rockets and bombs and sustained heavy
machine gun fire that went on for a
couple of hours we saw trucks of
Congolese presidential guard driving
towards the front they're one of the
best trained and equipped units in
Congo's Army this is where the people
who have fled end up in shelters in
camps for displaced people this one's
made of a mosquito net it's not going to
keep out the rain neither is this scrap
of plastic sheeting the people from here
have sought shelter elsewhere but they
were trying to cook some food but
everyone here says there isn't enough
food there isn't much clean water this
time a week ago the UN said nearly 200
000 people have been displaced by the
conflict and that was before the
population of kibumba fled